♫
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THE WHITE HOUSE HELD WHAT
THEY DESCRIBED AS A
LISTENING SESSION TODAY
WHERE SURVIVORS OF LAST
WEEK’S FLORIDA SHOOTING
GATHERED WITH THE PARENTS OF
CHILDREN KILLED IN PREVIOUS
SHOOTINGS TO DISCUSS WHAT
THE COUNTRY OUGHT TO BE
DOING GOING FORWARD.
SAID.
>> WE MUST CREATE A CULTURE
OF CONNECTEDNESS.
WE MUST CREATE A CULTURE IN
WHICH OUR CLASSMATES BECOME
OUR FRIENDS.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS HAVE BEEN
FROM YOUNG MEN WHO ARE
DISCONNECTED.
>> ONE SCHOOL SHOOTING AND
WE SHOULD HAVE FIXED IT.
AND I’M PISSED BECAUSE MY
DAUGHTER I’M NOT GOING TO
SEE AGAIN.
>> I WANT TO FEEL SAFE AT
SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW, SENIOR YEAR AND
JUNIOR YEAR ARE BIG YEARS
FOR ME WHEN I TURN MY
ACADEMICS ARRANGED, STARTED
CONNECTING WITH TEACHERS AND
I STARTED ACTUALLY ENJOYING
SCHOOL.
AND NOW I DON’T KNOW HOW I’M
GOING TO STEP FOOT ON THAT
SCHOOL AGAIN.
>> TEACHERS GUN ON THEM GO.
FOR SPECIAL TRAINING AND
THEY WOULD THEREBY AND YOU
WOULD NO LONGER HAVE A
GUN-FREE ZONE.
GUN-FREE ZONE TO A MANIAC
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL
COWARDS, A GUN-FREE ZONE IS
LET’S GO IN AND LET’S ATTACK
BECAUSE BULLETS AREN’T
COMING BACK AT US.
>> Tucker: YOU FEEL FOR
THOSE KIDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
SEEMS LIKELY A POLITICAL
MATTER THAT SOME SOME OF GUN
CONTROL MAY BE COMING.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS SIGNALED
SUPPORT FOR STRICTER
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
FEDERAL BAN ON BURDEN OF
PROOF STOCKS.
THAT’S NOT CLOSE TO WHAT
MANY ON THE LEFT ARE
DEMANDING.
YOU SAW SOME OF THOSE
DEMANDS TODAY AT WIDELY
TELEVISED.
PARKLAND, IT’S
UNDERSTANDABLE.
PEOPLE BECOME POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS ALL THE TIME IN
RESPONSE TO TRAGEDIES.
THAT’S THEIR RIGHT.
NOBODY OUGHT TO ATTACK THEM
FOR IT.
WE ARE CERTAINLY NOT
ATTACKING THEM.
WE NEVER WOULD.
WE ASSUME THEY HAVE THE BEST
MOTIVES.
MOST OF US HAVE THE BEST
ALMOST EVERYBODY IS AGAINST
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DO YOU
DO ABOUT THEM?
NOW, IF YOU WATCH A LOT OF
CABLE NEWS, YOU KNOW THAT
THE ANSWER IS SIMPLE.
YOU SIMPLY STOP TAKING MONEY
FROM THE NRA AND DO YOU
SOMETHING ABOUT GUNS.
NOT ANYTHING SPECIFIC, JUST
SOMETHING.
BUT, FIRST, YOU HAVE TO
DEFEAT THE EVIL
CONSERVATIVES WHO LOVE
SCHOOL MASSACRES.
ONCE DO YOU THAT THE
VIOLENCE WILL GO AWAY LIKE
MAGIC.
THAT’S THE DEMAGOGUES ON THE
OTHER CHANNELS ARE TELLING
YOU.
THEY USE THE TRAUMATIZED
CHILDREN OF PARKLAND AS A
HUMAN SHIELD.
ASK THEM WHAT THEY ARE
CALLING FOR, ASK THEM TO
DESCRIBE THESE POLICIES,
SUPPOSEDLY FIX EVERYTHING.
AND THESE CHILDLESS NEWS
ANCHORS SCREECH THAT YOU ARE
ATTACKING THE CHILDREN.
IT’S FUNNY, EVERY JANUARY
THOUSANDS OF OTHER CHILDREN
COME TO WASHINGTON FOR THE
MARCH ON LIFE.
LIKE THE KIDS FROM PARKLAND,
THEY ARE AGAINST KILLING.
SOME OF THEM HAVE HAD
ABORTIONS.
A FEW OF THEM HAVE SURVIVED
DO THE MEDIA HOLD THESE KIDS
UP AS THE LAST WORD ON THE
SUBJECT?
DO THEY ATTACK ANYONE WHO
QUESTIONS THEM?
PLEASE, A LOT OF NEWS
OUTLETS DON’T EVEN BOTHER TO
COVER THAT MARCH AT ALL.
ALL KIDS AT ANY MARCH, JUST
LIKE ALL AMERICANS HAVE A
RIGHT TO TALK.
AND TO DO SO IN PUBLIC TO
GIVE THEIR OPINIONS
ANYWHERE, INCLUDING ON
TELEVISION.
UNLIKE MANY ON THE LEFT, WE
SUPPORT THAT RIGHT
UNEQUIVOCALLY IN EVERY CASE.
BUT THE REST OF US ALSO HAVE
A RIGHT TO ADD OUR VOICES TO
THE CONVERSATION.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO DO
THAT.
BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE A STAKE
IN THIS COUNTRY’S LAWS.
THEN THE TRUTH IS, THIS IS A
REMARKABLY COMPLICATED
SUBJECT.
THAT’S WHY WE HAVEN’T FIXED
IT YET.
ANY ANSWER HAS TO BALANCE
OUR NEED FOR SAFETY WITH
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT THIS IS
A CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
IT’S NOT THE SET OF MORNING
JOE.
FOR EXAMPLE, PRETTY MUCH
EVERYBODY AGREES THAT
EVERYBODY WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS SHOULD NOT HAVE
FIREARMS.
THAT SOUNDS SIMPLE.
WHAT DO YOU WITH MORE THAN
400,000 IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN
VETS WHO HAVE RECEIVED A
DIAGNOSIS OF PTSD.
THAT’S A MENTAL DISORDER.
SHOULD THEY LOSE THEIR
RIGHTS TO GUN OWNERSHIP
BECAUSE THEY WERE INJURED BY
WAR?
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT’S NOT SO
SIMPLE.
OR HOW ABOUT DOMESTIC
ABUSERS?
NOBODY THINKS THEY SHOULD
HAVE GUNS.
WEAVE DON’T, OBVIOUSLY.
WHAT IF THEY HAVEN’T BEEN
CONVICTED OF ANYTHING YET?
CAN YOU STRIP RIGHTS FROM
SOMEBODY WHO IS LEGALLY
INNOCENT?
AND IF YOU TAKE THEIR GUN
RIGHTS AWAY, HOW ABOUT THEIR
VOTING RIGHTS OR FREE SPEECH
RIGHTS?
WE’RE NOT SURE OF THE
ANSWERS TO THOSE.
BUT WE’RE POSITIVE THEY ARE
REAL QUESTIONS.
THEY NEED TO BE DEBATED AND
CONSIDERED BY SMART PEOPLE,
SINCERELY TRYING TO MAKE THE
COUNTRY BETTER.
THE MEDIA SCREECHER ARE NOT
HELPING.
THEY ARE TELLING US IT’S A
SIMPLE FIX AS LONG AS YOU
CARE ENOUGH.
THAT’S A LIE AND THEY’RE
USING CHILDREN TO TELL THAT
LIE.
SPARE US.
WE’RE FOR THE CHILDREN.
WE’RE NOT FOR YOU.
CONGRESSMAN JIM HINES A
DEMOCRAT WHO REPRESENTS
CONNECTICUT HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, UNLIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE YOU BEEN
SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT YOU
WANT.
I ADMIRE THAT YOU WERE ON
CNN ON MONDAY AND I’M
QUOTING NOW WE WANT TO BE NO
DIFFERENT FROM CANADA OR
AUSTRALIA OR GREAT BRITAIN.
SO, IN AUSTRALIA, AND YOU
HEAR THIS A LOT FROM THE
LEFT, 650,000 GUNS WERE
CONFISCATED FROM CITIZENS.
AND THAT’S WHAT YOU ARE
CALLING FOR.
WHO WOULD DO THAT?
WHO WOULD TAKE THOSE GUNS IN
THIS COUNTRY?
>> NO.
THAT’S NOT WHAT I’M CALLING
FOR, TUCKER.
AUSTRALIA IS A PRETTY GOOD
EXAMPLE BECAUSE AFTER THE
MASSACRE OF 35 OF ITS
CITIZENS IN PORT ARTHUR IN
1996 THEY IMPLEMENTED A
WHOLE SERIES.
I DON’T USUALLY AGREE WITH
YOU TUCKER YOU ARE RIGHT.
THIS IS A COMPLICATED
PROBLEM THAT WON’T GET
SOLVED CERTAINLY BY THE
MEDIA ON EITHER SIDE IT WILL
GET SOLD EITHER TIME NOT
PERFECTLY BY LOTS OF
MEASURES SOME OF WHICH WERE
TRIED BY AUSTRALIA.
AUSTRALIA DOESN’T HAVE A
SECOND AMENDMENT.
THEY ARE NOT THE BEST
EXAMPLE.
WE DO KNOW IF WEEKEND GET
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECK
NO MATTER WHERE YOU BUY A
GUN, YOU GET A BACKGROUND
CHECK.
WE DO KNOW IF YOU COULD FIND
A WAY AND I ADMIT THAT IT IS
COMPLICATED WITH RIGHTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WITH
ORDERS, TEMPORARILY GIVE UP
THEIR WEAPONS.
IF YOU COULD DO A WHOLE
BUNCH OF THOSE THINGS, THERE
IS NO QUESTION THAT LIKE
AUSTRALIA, WE COULD SEE OUR
GUN VIOLENCE IN THIS COUNTRY
PLUMMET.
>> Tucker: THERE IS A
QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
WE DON’T ACTUALLY KNOW.
WE HAD THE ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN OF 1994.
IT SEEMED LIKE IT WOULD
REDUCE KILLINGS AND IT
DIDN’T.
WE KNOW THAT CONCLUSIVELY.
YOU ARE NEVER QUITE SURE
WHAT THE EFFECT IS.
YOU TWICE POINTED TO
AUSTRALIA AS A MODEL FOR GUN
POLICY HERE.
SO WHAT SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
AUSTRALIA.
AGAIN, A COUNTRY THAT
CONFISCATED ITS CITIZENS’
GUNS BY THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS.
WHAT DID THEY DO.
>> CAN YOU KEEP USING THE
WORD CONFISCATION.
>> Tucker: THEY DID THAT’S A
FACT.
>> IT’S ALSO A FACT THAT
THEY INSUBSTITUTE ADD
MANDATORY WAITING PERIOD FOR
THE PURCHASE OF A GUN.
IT IS ALSO A FACT THAT THEY
INSTITUTED A UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECK.
TWO THINGS THAT WE DON’T
HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
MIGHT BE CONSIDERED
CONSTITUTIONAL.
SO YOU CAN LEAVE THE
CONFISCATION BEHIND BECAUSE
THAT’S NOT WHAT ANYBODY IS
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS THE
ESSENCE OF WHAT THEY DID.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO OWN A
GUN IN AUSTRALIA EXCEPT
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
THE GOVERNMENT SAYS YOU HAVE
GOT A RIGHT TO.
SAME WITH YIN.
YOU POINTED TO GREAT
BRITAIN.
IN GREAT BRITAIN YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO OWN A GUN.
YOU HAVE TO PROVE THAT YOU
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO HAVE
ONE.
ARE YOU CALLING FOR THAT?
>> NO.
I’M NOT.
IN BOTH OF THOSE COUNTRIES
IN THE ABSENCE OF A SECOND
AMENDMENT, YOU ARE RIGHT.
YOU HAVE TO SHOW A CAUSE.
A REASON TO HAVE A GUN.
WE HAVE A SECOND AMENDMENT
IN THIS COUNTRY WHICH YOU
MAY BE SURPRISED TO HEAR I
SUPPORT.
SO.
>> Tucker: DOESN’T SOUND
LIKE IT?
>> REQUIRE THE CITIZENS:
YOU CAN SAY THAT AS MUCH AS
YOU WANT, TUCKER THAT’S NOT
TRUE.
>> Tucker: I’M SAYING THAT
IN RESPONSE TO WHAT YOU
SAID.
>> WHAT I’M CALLING FOR THE
PRESIDENT -- I’M NOT USUALLY
IN THE HABIT OF PRAISING THE
PRESIDENT, WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS SAID HE IS
WILLING TO CONSIDER.
THINGS LIKE TIGHTENING UP
THE BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THINGS LIKE RESTRICTIONS ON
TECHNOLOGY LIKE BUMP STOCKS.
NOBODY IS CALLING FOR
CONFISCATION OR FOR
EVERYTHING THEY DO IN
AUSTRALIA OR GREAT BRITAIN.
>> Tucker: JUST TO BE CLEAR,
DON’T PAINT ME AS A
DEMAGOGUE.
YOU JUST SAID THIS TWO DAYS
AGO ON CNN.
YOU POINTED SPECIFICALLY TO
A COUNTRY THAT GOT RID OF
GUN VIOLENCE BECAUSE THEY
GOT RID OF GUNS.
I THINK IT’S A FAIR QUESTION
TO ASK WHEN YOU POINT TO
AUSTRALIA, WHY ARE YOU NOT
CALLING FOR CONFISCATION
BECAUSE THAT’S THE CORE
THING THEY DID.
>> FIRST OF ALL AUSTRALIA
DID NOT GET RID OF GUNS.
STILL A LOT OF GUNS IN
AUSTRALIA.
PLENTY OF GUNS IN CANADA AND
PLENTY OF GUN NOTICE UNITED
KINGDOM.
THESE ARE COUNTRIES THAT ARE
DIFFERENT THAN OTHER OWN.
NO, THEY DID NOT GET RID OF
GUNS IN ANY ONE OF THOSE
COUNTRIES.
YOU KEEP TALKING ABOUT
AUSTRALIA.
I NEVER CALLED FOR
CONFISCATION.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE THE ONE
TALKING ABOUT AUSTRALIA NOT
ME.
>> AUSTRALIA IS A GOOD MODEL
IN ONE WAY WHICH WAS THAT
AFTER A TRAGEDY 35 PEOPLE
DEAD IN PORT ARTHUR.
THEY GOT TOGETHER, THE PRIME
MINISTER AND SIX STATES GOT
TOGETHER AND SAID LET’S PASS
A PACKAGE OF GUN SAFETY
CHANGES THAT WILL REDUCE
VIOLENCE.
NOW, NOT ALL OF THOSE
CHANGES WOULD APPLY IN THE
UNITED STATES AND I’M NOT
CALLING FOR THAT.
>> Tucker: LIKE TAKING THEM
AWAY BY FORCE FROM THE
POPULATION.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
>> AGAIN, CAN YOU KEEP SAY
THAT BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT
ANYBODY IS CALLING FOR.
>> Tucker: I’M SORRY.
I KNOW A LOT ABOUT THIS AND
THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE BILL.
>> NO THAT WAS A PART OF THE
BILL THAT I’M NOT CALLING
FOR AND FRANKLY ALMOST
NOBODY IS CALLING FOR
CONFISCATION.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU
THIS, THOSE COUNTRIES ALL
HAVE UNIVERSAL GUN
REGISTRATION.
YOU OWN A GUN YOU HAVE TO
REGISTER WITH THE
GOVERNMENT.
ARE YOU FOR THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, THEY ACTUALLY
CANCELLED THE UNIVERSAL GUN
REGISTRATION IN AUSTRALIA
BECAUSE THEY FELT THAT IT
WAS MORE OF A BURDEN ON
LEGAL GUN OWNERS.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU FOR IT
WAS THE QUESTION.
>> NO.
I’M NOT NECESSARILY FOR IT
IN THE UNITED STATES.
I AM FOR EVERYBODY HAVING A
BACKGROUND CHECK.
I AM FOR PEOPLE WITH
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDERS
TEMPORARILY GIVING UP THEIR
GUNS.
I AM FOR A LIMIT ON THE SIZE
OF THE MAGAZINE THAT YOU CAN
USE.
THINGS THAT WE HAVE DONE
HERE IN THE STATE OF
CONNECTICUT WHICH HAVE BEEN
CONSTITUTIONAL.
AND HAVE NOT RESULTED IN
PEOPLE’S SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS BEING VIOLATED IN
CONNECTICUT.
>> Tucker: I WAS WONDERING
THIS.
YOU WORK UP ON CAPITOL HILL
SURROUNDED BY ARMED GUARDS.
DO YOU THINK THEY HAVE TOO
MANY GUNS AND DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT THEIR MAGAZINES HOLD
TOO MANY ROUNDS AND IF NOT
WHY NOT?
>> TUCKER, NICE TRY.
YOU’RE NOT GOING TO GET ME
TO SAY.
>> Tucker: IT’S A SINCERE
QUESTION THEY PROTECT YOU.
YOU FEEL SAFE WITH A LOT OF
PEOPLE WITH HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINES BUT I’M NOT
ALLOWED TO HAVE THEM IN MY
HOUSE TO PROTECT MY FAMILY
WOULD BE PERFECTLY HAPPY
WITH THE GENERAL PUBLIC
HAVING THE SAME FIREARMS
THAT THE CAPITAL POLICE HAVE
IF THE GENERAL PUBLIC WERE
LIKE CAPITAL POLICE REQUIRED
TO UNDERGO A CRIMINAL CHECK,
REQUIRED TO RECERTIFY
THEMSELVES EVERY SINGLE YEAR
FOR THE USE OF THOSE
FIREARMS, AND PERSONALLY
ACCOUNTABLE AND
PROFESSIONALLY ACCOUNTABLE
FOR HOW THEY ARE USED.
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO PUT
ALL THOSE RESTRICTIONS ON
THE GENERAL PUBLIC’S RIGHT
TO OWN FIREARMS.
WHAT POLICE HAVE AND MARINES
HAVE SIGN ME UP.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU
ONE LAST QUESTION.
>> NICE TRY MY FRIEND.
CONFUSED BY THE DETAILS YOU
ENDORSED THE MOST RECENT
ITERATION OF THE ASSAULT
WITHIN A.
I HAVE ASKED THIS QUESTION
OF A LOT OF LAWMAKERS.
BAN BARREL SHROUD.
THOSE WOULD BE ILLEGAL.
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS A BARREL
SHROUD AND WHY WOULD YOU
BAN?
>> A BARREL SHROUD AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW BECAUSE HAVE
YOU TALKED TO OTHER GUESTS
ABOUT IT COVERING ON THE
BARREL OF A GUN THAT ALLOWED
YOU TO HOLD THAT GUN WHEN
THE BARREL HAS OVERHEATED
BECAUSE OF MULTIPLE ROUNDS
BEING FIRED.
>> Tucker: THAT’S RIGHT.
>> SO WE AGREE ON THAT.
I’M NOT ALL THAT WORKED UP
OVER BARREL SHROUDS AND NOT
INTERESTED IN SAYING THAT AN
ASSAULT WITHIN BAN WILL
SOLVE OUR PROBLEMS.
I HAPPEN TO SUPPORT A BAN ON
TECHNOLOGY THAT ALLOWS YOU
TO GET SQUEEZE OFF 20 OR 30
ROUNDS IN A MINUTE OR TWO.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL THAT WOULD
HAVE BANNED THAT AND PISTOL
GRIPS AND FOLDING STOCKS AND
BAYONET LUGS AND ALL THESE
THINGS THAT ARE IRRELEVANT?
IT MAKES YOU SEEM NOT
SERIOUS IF YOU SUPPORT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, LOTS OF STATES
HAVE APASSED ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN.
I HEARD YOU TALKING ABOUT
THE DESIRE OF THE POPULIST
EARLIER.
A LOT OF STATES INCLUDING MY
STATE OF CONNECTICUT ASSAULT
WEAPON BAN.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO DIE
IN THIS COUNTRY AS A RESULT
OF ASSAULT WEAPONS, THOUGH
THEY MAKE THE HEADLINES THAT
IS A RELATIVELY SMALL
PERCENTAGE.
>> Tucker: I’M AWARE OF
THAT.
>> NONETHELESS I DON’T WANT
PEOPLE TO HAVE GUNS THAT
ALLOW THEM AND MOST POLICE
OFFICERS DON’T WANT THEM TO
HAVE GUNS THAT ALLOW THEM TO
SQUEEZE OFF 20 TO 30 ROUNDS
VERY RAPIDLY WITHOUT
RELOADING.
LOOK, YOU ASKED ABOUT BARREL
SHROUDS.
>> Tucker: I’M SORRY,
YOU UNPACK IT ALL AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS